[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh you know we've had
some great episodes and I've had a lot
of emails responses to the episodes and
I really appreciate that I try to bring
guests that you may not know sometimes
but that will open up kind of uh maybe
you can relate to some of the things
they're saying maybe some of it helps
you uh things that I find interesting
and uh I just wanna
it's sort of about Humanity
you know how people evolve and where
they come from and how they tick and how
they deal with loss and all these things
and and I I really am enjoying the
podcast more than I have ever because I
think I'm really just
more relaxed now
the learning curve is over folks you're
dealing with a professional interviewer
here
and I will say that
um please follow us and write a review
if you're liking the podcast it helps
substantially there's there's so many
podcasts and if you really like this and
go hey I like him interviewing and I
like his style Please Subscribe and
write review it helps to show immensely
and we're a little show we're like the
Little Red Caboose that could or
whatever
um our handles are this outside if you
pod on Twitter outside of your podcast
on Instagram and Facebook that's right
if you want to join patreon The Lovable
Patron all my patrons support the
podcast to give back something that
really helps uh in more ways than one go
to patreon.com inside of you become a
patron today uh there's so many perks
and so much fun we do so many great
things and last but not least the inside
of you online store you can get great
merch Smallville merch uh podcast merch
and go to sunspin.com my band and get
some cool swag there uh my span Sun spin
the album never is what it is is out
streaming everywhere so I'd love you if
you could take a listen but more
importantly we got a very important
guest today
no we always have an important guest uh
Brent Spiner is um and Jonathan Frakes
hooked us up I think I might have met
Brent a while back
but this was uh I said hey could you get
and and he you know emailed his buddy
they're good friends in fact they're
gonna do maybe a reality show which I'll
talk about on uh on this podcast
um and Brent says yeah have him email me
and he can't he came over and my dog
Blanche almost bit him and she's never
been aggressive with anybody so thank
you Brent uh no this was a great
interview and
um there are you know he's got a lot to
say about uh the Picard
show
so a lot of uh cool responses from and
also you know career and all that
important stuff and dealing with life
and
um
we cover a lot in this hour so I
appreciate you thanks for listening
Please Subscribe uh if you like it and
without further Ado let's get inside of
Brent Spiner it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience all right well first of all
it's an honor to have you here well
thank you I've heard so much I think I
met you briefly at a con or something oh
hey but you meet millions of people
right oh I mean listen I I'll never
forget meeting you
he's such a liar already a liar you and
my mother get along well
liar no
um the first thing you started talking
about and by the way
um my dog Blanche was a little bit timid
around you it was weird he's the nicest
guy and it's just she's so weird
sometimes but she's like she just has to
warm up I don't get it I love her and uh
yeah I hurt yeah you know if John Hamm
your daughter that's my dog if I if John
Ham treated me like that I'd be a little
bit he might I mean you know what's
weird he treats me like that too really
yeah he's like I don't know do you have
a treat okay well a lot of people are
thinking did he just say his dog's name
is John Hamm yes and he told me that
story but your your son yeah the dog was
eating ham no no the dog was a part of a
litter that we adopted the dog from a
litter that they had named all of the
litter uh with pizza toppings oh right
right right and and her dog was named
ham and we didn't particularly love that
but then my son went well what about Jon
Hamm because madman is his favorite show
of all time and so uh when we went yeah
Jon Hamm good and you've never met Jon
Hamm no I've never met him but if you
met him would they be the first thing to
break the ice is what you'd say my dog's
Jon Hamm totally that'd be the very
first thing well I might say hey we
watched Fletch the other night was great
was he in Fletch yeah he was Fletch
there's a new flesh right is it is it
good yeah it's good uh it's he's he's
terrific he's always good uh and it's
not great but it's good and it really
has a real kind of 70s feel to it 80s
feel to it it's it's really clever there
those are big shoes to fill I think yeah
but I mean Tom Hammond is fantastic he
is and I've met him a couple of times my
friends really close friends with him
from Madden my friend Jay Ferguson name
dropper yeah and uh you know I'm he's
just he's a guy's guy he's just like hey
man how's it going uh what's up yeah
Cowboys uh I think they're gonna win
this yeah he's great I I don't know
anyone uh I'm trying to think if I know
anyone from Mad Men uh oh well I knew uh
Bobby Morris but I don't want to drop
names I remember Zach Galifianakis he
had in between two firms and he had John
hams he goes John Hammond goes do any
does anyone ever call you um John's
sausage links and he goes no they don't
so you're on a show called um he goes um
madman Madman Madden he goes Mad Men yes
and it was a story about 60 year old men
no no it takes place in the 60s I just
remember that that was a great show it
was good there's nobody like that guy
Zach was he's so funny oh he's hilarious
yeah I did one thing with him I did a uh
comedy uh Comedy Bang Bang Yeah you know
that show sounds perverted but yeah no
it was a really funny show on Comedy
Central I did an episode and he was on
it too do you do a lot of Comedy
I mean you did a lot of Comedy for sure
I mean you were like
that and back in the day you were doing
that's all you were doing you were you
were funny you were like I mean not that
you're not funny but like you know I
mean memorable Parts like night court
right people always remember that right
Night Court totally I can't tell you how
many people say to me uh Bob Wheeler on
Nightcore are you gonna be on the new
Night Court are you well let me say this
they have to ask me though they I can't
just show up so no no one's asked you
yet no there was a thing uh there was at
the critics Association this year
apparently I wasn't there but somebody
told me that they asked laraquette uh is
Brent spine are going to be on the show
and he went well I'm not sure we could
afford him anymore and you know I
thought about that and I thought yeah
he's probably right
yeah no there's no such thing as scale
in my world anymore I mean do you do you
do things still for I mean you have such
a body of work you've done so many
things do you still take on jobs that is
it more like if I like the content I'll
consider it and it's not about the money
or do you have to be paid there's
something that you know I want to be
paid here but you know I mean obviously
content is first right I mean not that I
wouldn't do lousy shows
we all have my career I mean I've made
some of the worst movies of all time
what movie is the worst of all time
well I mean I I you know they're almost
Classics uh it I did a movie that is a
classic I think in it's called Uh Master
of Disguise uh oh do you know that movie
yes
yeah yeah I do I haven't seen it but yes
Dana wrote it and uh it's it was uh he
wrote it for his two nine-year-old boys
at the time and right and it truly is a
film for nine-year-old boys but uh
didn't do well it didn't do well but it
was so much fun to work on isn't that
funny how the worst movies
uh you know according to critics and
whatever and how well it does yeah
um are the ones that you had the most
when I did a movie called sorority boys
and people love it it's Colt and I had
the most fun I've ever had on a movie
and I don't regret doing it for one
minute no I think it's funny oh my uncle
thinks it's the funniest movie he's ever
seen he hates everything I've done I I
understand I love Master of Disguise in
its in its terribleness but uh and and
it's it was so much fun you know what
happened with that film uh Dana wrote
the film and uh Adam Sandler produced it
and you know Adam has this group of
people who work with him all the time
and uh his crew and uh he kind of looked
around he says who wants to direct this
movie and uh he nobody raised their hand
and so he said the DP you want to do
this movie and he said no and so finally
the uh the art director said I'll direct
the movie and so he's okay you're the
director and he was and uh the art
director director of the movie yeah the
art director of all of Adams films
directed uh Master of Disguise and uh
and I have to say he directed very much
like any wonderful director you've ever
worked with it was like you know I had
ideas and he would say let's try it
again and you know it was great that's
amazing you know
when we got in here before we were
rolling
we talked about William Shatner and he
just talked turned 92 years old yeah and
um you said you just had dinner with him
last night Saturday or Saturday night
are you close friends with William we're
friends I do call him bill yeah you
don't call him chat no no uh there is a
famous story however of uh you know he
famously or not so famously to to people
who don't know theater but he one of his
big hits on Broadway when he was a young
man was a shot in the dark which later
became a Peter Sellers film he didn't
play that role it was completely
Rewritten but uh it was Bill and Walter
Matthau and apparently Mattel told me
this story that uh Judy Holliday came
back afterwards and she said this guy
Shatner is is his name in the past tense
it's funny because I do say that to my
friends I'm gonna go take a Bill Shatner
and you know I don't think he'd
appreciate that I doubt it but no uh
yeah I'm friends with Bill and and uh
you call him uh if I need to or a text I
have I have done yeah yeah what would
you and Bill text about well one time uh
uh somebody
somebody
tweeted me privately that uh he had
can't he had what do you call it when he
he blocked them and uh and they were
really upset about it I'm so sorry I but
I can't I don't know what to do how do I
apologize with you I said look don't
worry about it he probably doesn't write
those things anyway or have anything to
do with it and uh and then I get this
this text from him or uh and it said not
from him uh wasn't attacked it was a
direct message saying what in the hell
is wrong with you why would you say
something like that and I thought oh my
God if I overstep so I called him and uh
he happened to be in and he came to the
phone I said Bill I'm so sorry I you
know I didn't realize that was I was
crossing the line with that and he said
what are you talking about and I said
and he didn't know anything about it oh
my God so someone writing for him yeah
but you know what's he like I mean when
you're hanging out and having dinner
with him I didn't even think I was going
to ask you this question until you
brought up dinner with him but like is
he fun I'm sure he has endless stories
endless and but he's also one of the
most well-read people oh yeah ever me I
go to cons and his face is buried in a
book always every time always and and uh
he's so knowledgeable he really is and
he's so interested in the world I think
that's why he's who he is now he's uh
his energy is unbelievable uh he has way
more energy than I do me too and uh he's
uh he's just a voracious reader he's
interested in all sorts of subjects
anything about uh you know space space
but the world uh trees bees Birds you'll
read books about them I mean he's just a
fascinating guy do you like having a
friend who knows everything uh because I
have a friend who thinks he knows
everything my friend Tom Lally this guy
I will say you know I might do this show
but he's like well there's a show like
that I'm like no there's not and we dig
something up and that no one's even seen
I'm just saying what I'm saying yeah he
just knows he can't say anything without
him saying he knows something I I I know
more than one person like that and and
you don't hang out with them much uh no
I actually do uh but uh it is tedious I
have to say yes yeah I like to have
conversations and where no one knows the
answer it's sort of ambiguous you know
you'll find in this interview I know
nothing you know nothing right
inside he was brought to you by rocket
money listen up because you are going to
save money and this isn't BS this is
real rocket money uh it's amazing
because it helps you cancel all those
subscriptions that you don't want that
you didn't do you still had and I wanted
to watch some Discovery show called MILF
Manor and I swear I don't know why but I
just wanted to see what it was about
because my friend said it's ridiculous
and it was
um but I forgot to cancel it and also
five months I'm like I don't have
Discovery because I only watched that
show and I blew like 50 bucks
and that was just one subscription
rocket money I mean stop throwing your
money away that's what I'm telling
myself and I'm telling you look rocket
money is a personal finance app it finds
and cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place
over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about and
chances are you're one of them like that
stars app just to watch one show or that
free gaming trial you never actually
used
yeah rocket money also helps you manage
all your finances in one place and
automatically categorizes your expenses
so you can easily track your budget in
real time and also get alerted if
anything looks off this is what you need
if you don't if you can't afford a
business manager which is this is like
kind of like a business manager this is
like saying hey you're spending too much
why do you have this it's so easy and uh
look everybody out there stop throwing
your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions manage your expenses the
easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
slash inside that's rocketmoney.com
inside one more time rocketmoney.com
slash inside this show is sponsored by
betterhelp when you're at your best you
can do great things but sometimes life
gets you bogged down and you may feel
overwhelmed or like you're not showing
up in the way you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you and who couldn't use a few
better coping skills to be able to
handle all of life's curveballs look if
you're thinking of giving you therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
[Music]
um when you were a young boy I mean it
was I read this I was like I don't know
if you ever talked about it maybe I'm
sure you have
but I know your father passed away when
he was 29 years old when you were like
10 months old right
was that um it's something obviously you
weren't aware of having a father so it
was no you have no recollection of
anything at 10 months old but
um
did it may as you got older when were
you told by your mother that this had
happened when you understood it it
seemed to always be an awareness of it I
don't know when she exactly told me but
uh I mean certainly as soon as I could
understand anything I was aware that I
didn't have a father and uh my mother
was single at her brother and uh she
raised both of us for many years yeah
was was that something that you sort of
found difficult but didn't realize it
was difficult and it you later on you
realized that it was affecting you a
certain way not having a father around
it didn't seem difficult at the time
because my mother really just dug in and
did everything my mother's still alive
by the way she's 96. and she's close to
97 and uh wow still sharp as attack
really yeah how beautiful is that did
she live close no she lives in Houston
do you see her a couple times a year
yeah as often as I can and you talked to
her how often every day
you know it's it's she doesn't have a
lot of you know
doesn't have a lot of joy in her life
right now because
her husband is not well and he's in a
facility and uh he's actually 11 years
younger than her and that was a big
surprise to her that she would wind up
having to take care of him
um but so so I feel like I can give her
you know something to look forward to
every day and uh it's it cost me nothing
and and I enjoyed talking to her because
she's sharp and and interesting and you
know was she one of those mothers who
never asked you for anything or she
always someone else buy me a house no no
no never ask for anything anything oh
you're so lucky but when we were kids
she was like you know she played ball
with us you know she'd go out and you
know play catch with us and whatever we
needed uh she was great and she was
always loving and whatever you wanted to
do she said yeah she wasn't like hey the
acting thing let's go in a different
direction that's nothing
totally supportive uh even you know I
mean when I was first in New York I
didn't have any money and so every now
and then I'd call and I'd say listen uh
could I borrow some money and you know
uh and she'd send me some money and
I would you know got to the point uh can
I you think I could borrow a thousand
dollars uh because I had to pay my rent
and live and eat and all that stuff and
uh she did it continuously until one day
she finally uh said I said can I borrow
a thousand dollars she said I tell you
what
I'm gonna send you five thousand dollars
and uh what five I'm rich and she said
but that's the last money I'm gonna send
you and you're gonna have to either make
something happen or invest get an apple
right I should have yeah you know or
come home there was a family business
and uh business no well that there was
initially she was in the furniture
business but my grandfather
my grandfather invented to my knowledge
uh frosty root beer I don't know if you
know remember Frosty okay I do remember
yeah
but at some point in time very early on
he sold the recipe and uh kept the
bottling and so he he had a big bottling
and he made bottles and and sold bottles
and cans and containers was his stuff is
that a lucrative business it was he did
very well and all of my family except me
worked uh for Tex Berry Container
Corporation and um did they expect you
did grandfather think Brent when are you
gonna do it no I I think they thought uh
what is he gonna do you know but but uh
no so that everybody was pretty good
with my going into show business but um
but this game you know finally it hit
the wall and my mother said you know
you gotta you gotta make something
happen or or come back and work here
yeah and uh and fortunately something
happened and I started to work and I
didn't need to ever borrow another dime
what made you want to get into acting
well uh I mean you're in Houston right
yeah and there's probably not is there a
lot of theater in Houston at the time
well the alley theater was in Houston it
was a well-known regional theater in
Houston and uh had great uh directors
and actors uh and but I never worked
there uh but uh I had a teacher in high
school
um his name was Cecil Pickett uh he was
a brilliant man who encouraged a lot of
people uh my drama class at uh Ballard
High School uh with the people in my
drama class were like uh Randy and
Dennis Quaid and they knew them and uh
Tommy schlami Thomas yeah was in my
drama class Marianne Williamson who's
running for president you know again uh
it was quite uh but but it was all
because of Mr Pickett because he had a
real nose for talent and if you were
invited into the six period drama class
uh that was something was special right
and he was a wonderful director and
teacher but more than anything I think
he gave me a sense that I had something
to offer and I think that's what he did
for for all those people I mentioned and
others many others you know it is I've
talked about this before but it's you
have to have someone someone along the
way yeah whether it's one person or a
few people that inspire you that
um give you this confidence that you you
know you build yeah um and if you don't
have it I don't know how you can do it
without someone believing in you how can
you believe in yourself yeah exactly and
if you're lucky enough to have someone
like that or a particularly a teacher
someone you already respect and admire
that says to you I think you're going to
do it you know go for it yeah I had a
you know Dr Bill Leonard he's still at
Western Kentucky University I don't
think he's teaching anymore but I went
in after it was my senior year and I
said yeah I'm thinking about going to
grad school for theater and he goes
go to New York
I go through grad school or something
you know I don't really know if I can
get in NYU or something yes now no go to
New York I think you're ready you I
don't think you should do that I think
you should go to New York yeah what a
blessing right I mean if he would have
said go to grad school I would have gone
yeah and he just yeah I I think if if uh
Mr Pickett had said to me uh you know no
don't don't don't do it I mean there are
other people too you know Brett Cullen I
do I know the name yeah Brett was there
there was a wonderful actor named Trey
Wilson who I was one of my best friends
and uh he was in the movie uh uh Bull
Durham he played the manager in Boulder
oh my God I loved him yeah he was in uh
raised in Arizona
and he had a craggy face he he looked 45
when he was 19. like a Wilford Brimley
yeah just always looked way older he
would have worked forever but he sadly
passed away when he was I think he was
39 40. what he was around his 40th
birthday yeah and you were close friends
very good friends yeah did you go to the
funeral uh yeah hi watching your friend
pass at that age it was one of the most
that was still one of the most shocking
events of my life the phone call I got
from another friend in New York who uh
said told me Trey passed away I was like
just knocked out I couldn't believe it
would he pass from he had a brain
aneurysm
um yeah and uh it was like gone yeah
yeah but he would have he was so gifted
and he would have done so much work I
think he did eight films the year he he
passed away
granny mahara was a dear friend of mine
and he passed a few years ago and he was
the smartest sweetest man I've ever
known yeah and he had a brain aneurysm
and it was just like that I met Grant
yeah yeah what a lovely guy right yeah
um you know when you're when you're
struggling in New York and you're doing
all these things what did you ever deal
with any sort of like depression or just
you know and I'm I should just go back I
should do or was it did it happen fast
it didn't happen fast uh but uh yeah I
was talking to my mother about this the
other night and I was saying you know I
she said she was like I gotta give you
credit you hung in there and you you
know and I said well you know arrogantly
I I kind of thought it's gonna be okay I
always thought it was gonna be okay and
uh so I never really got depressed I got
depressed about other things like being
dumped by a girlfriend or you know it's
like the worst yeah but uh it really is
it is you know the first time it happens
to you you think you're going to die
it's so painful it's like I don't know
yeah you lose yourself like what are you
doing I know you can't sleep you can't
eat you can't think and then you hate
yourself for going through that after
yeah you're going what is wrong with me
why can't I you know yeah but uh but no
the the show business thing I just I
just had confidence that it was gonna
happen or are you always good because I
everything it seems like you always
everything you do you always have a lot
of lines you always are you know boom
boom boom boom do you have this thing
called the photographic memory can you
can you learn things really fast no
but how do you play a guy like data
character like data well back in those
days uh when I was doing it you know
every day uh it is a muscle and uh you
know you get better and better and
better at it I used to have a deal with
myself I would go home
after 16 hours or whatever uh because we
were doing also 26 episodes a year back
then and um I'd come home and I'd say
okay let me open up the script and my
stomach would turn over you know I could
learn this for tomorrow for tomorrow
yeah and uh uh but I had to deal with
myself that if I if if I couldn't I
couldn't go to sleep until I could say
it out loud one time perfectly so I knew
I could do it the next day did you ever
have those nights where you didn't well
you know and the next day you struggled
there were a lot of times I didn't sleep
let me say that because I had that deal
with myself that unfortunate deal but uh
did you ever did you ever tell the
producers like hey can you back off a
little can you give me a little time to
learn this stuff I did have a I had
there was the first season or two on the
show uh we were all working all the time
and then finally The Producers sort of
figured out hey you know each one of
these guys could kind of carry a show
and we'll do data episodes we'll do
Picard episodes we'll do Riker you know
everybody had their shows and uh we
would you know there would always be
scenes on the bridge where you know we
would all be there and sometimes two
sometimes three you know it was always
fun to see who you're going to work with
that day but right
um but one or the other of us would
carry the show and uh I was doing a show
I I don't remember what the name of it
was but um
it was my show and so I was working all
day every day and everyone else had done
the first day and they were off the rest
of the time
and the day before we were starting a
new show and I was thinking oh thank God
this is going to be over soon and
somebody else's show I get this script
and they're like five characters I'm
playing five characters and it's again a
data show and uh oh sorry I'm getting
anxiety really so like I I've flown the
producer or one of the producers who was
still there and I said I can't do this I
mean this is how am I going to do this
I'm still working on this show and
tomorrow at some point in time we're
going to finish this and an hour later
start the next show and uh I've got five
characters I can't even read it much
less figure out what I'm gonna do with
them and her response her name was Jerry
Taylor a wonderful woman wonderful
producer and she said to me we have
faith in you
that was it I said oh okay see I
wouldn't have hung up I would have said
[__] off yeah well I know I can't I
cannot learn this I I well you know you
did it though I I managed to do it I
mean I gave one you know I did the
episode that we did where I played the
five characters is an episode called
masks and uh I only remember that
because I get a lot of feedback on it
but I do some of the most Preposterous
acting you've ever seen in your life in
it I mean the other actors were laughing
in my face at some of the characters I
was doing really literally you didn't
care no I mean there was a there was a
point the last when we finally got to
the end of it uh Patrick and I were in
masks and uh facing one another at two
o'clock on Saturday morning and uh he
was playing the god of the sun and I was
the goddess of the moon and we couldn't
get through the scene we were laughing
at each other so much that the crew
hated us
yeah yeah and you know but we couldn't
control no
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold
I see that much fun to work with Patrick
he can be he can be really fun I think
else I'm sure be intense well yeah
dramatic I'm sure you could all be
intense well you know to varying degrees
Yeah I'm usually the guy who you know
I'm gonna get my stuff done and get out
of there yeah
after I've done 100 episodes right in
the beginning you know but after a while
it's like hey let's do our thing and
let's get it oh yeah and we've got lives
that's great we know we know what we're
doing exactly were you ever like that uh
well I you know what I'm not very
intense or confrontational so I I you
know would more like say hey everybody
let's finish this and go home okay yeah
I understand um you know I text Jonathan
Frakes right before and I just said
um any inside scoop or questions for
Spiner interviewing him in an hour
and this is what he responded with
Judy Garland Joe DiMaggio Stephen
Sondheim Brent and Johnny show
how would you sum up those four things
well where shall we start uh it was Judy
Garland first yes it was well I met Judy
Garland when I was 16. uh we had a brief
no I'm kidding uh oh wow that would have
been awesome no no no uh it was just
this amazing thing and there's a photo I
have of it that when you when you run
this you'll want to like put the photo
up put that photo up Bryce yeah I'll
send it to you oh yeah but
um yeah I was in in I think I was in uh
I was in high school maybe my last year
of high school or junior year of high
school and I got a call to go to the
principal's office in the middle of the
day and I was like oh my God someone's
died and uh or I did something horrible
and um so I went to the principal's
office the principal of my high school
by the way uh Bellaire High School uh he
was his name was Harlan G Andrews and he
was uh the brother of the actor Dana
Andrews and uh another actor named Steve
Forrest the three of them were brothers
uh Dane Andrews fantastic actor right
um best years of Our Lives ah he gives
the best performance of them right he's
fantastic
um and uh very underrated but Harlan G
Andrews had white hair lots of it and uh
was craggy and handsome and uh
intimidating but he loved the theater he
was a big supporter of all the shows we
did uh anyway he said uh listen uh
someone's coming to pick you up you
gotta go home and that's when I thought
oh
this is going to be bad and he said no
no it's not bad it's you're gonna like
it and so
I was taken actually to the Shamrock
Hilton Hotel in Houston which doesn't
exist anymore it's a giant hotel in fact
it was the hotel that in the movie Giant
uh it's the hotel that jet rink it is
opening uh yeah James Dean yeah of
course anyway great place uh spent many
years there in my youth but uh
but so I go in I said what's the deal my
mother's there she says well we're going
to meet Judy Garland and I went what why
yeah and uh
my uncle
Ted Rogan was a promoter of sorts in
Houston and an advertising guy and but
he was a promoter and a PR guy and he
brought Judy Garland to the Astrodome to
perform at the Astrodome and uh her
opening act by the way was uh young
girls called The Supremes and um yeah
but there she was and I was introduced
to Judy Garland and uh are you
Starstruck well yeah I mean yeah you
know in my mind of course I'm thinking
Wizard of Oz you know but but she was a
grown woman and and uh very sweet very
nice to me I mean this jerky nerdy kid
16 year old and she took my arm and
asked me you know talk to me and uh they
took a photo of us and she signed it and
it's it is kind of my prized possession
how does it not that is
but it doesn't get better well it
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
any sense it's like you know and
particularly now when you see Judy
Garland and a young nerdy data
in a picture together right right uh but
yeah it was thrilling uh the second one
is Joe DiMaggio yeah well I just told
Jonathan this story the other day and
it's a lesson to all of us and me and
you and uh anyone uh but
uh my mother tells this story because
she was at a football game at Rice
stadium in Houston uh one Sunday uh and
she saw Joe DiMaggio and she went over
to him and she said oh my God Mr
DiMaggio it's so could I have your
autograph and he said well yeah all
right and she said oh I don't have a
pencil and he went well get a pencil and
she said okay she ran off to get a
pencil and she came back and he was gone
and to this day if you see well all
through my youth whenever the Mr Coffee
commercials would come on my mother
would say oh he's a terrible man
terrible man
because he wouldn't wait for her to go
get a pencil and I think about that as
you know where fans are concerned and
who want you know a moment of your time
and uh yeah you know I keep that I have
to go remember Joe DiMaggio remember you
know what I remember you always forget
the moments that I mean I signed a lot
of autographs and I I'm always very very
kind and open and energy energetic with
my fans and I love them and I was in a
football game where I grew up a high
school football game my old high school
and it was when Smallville first came
out I was mobbed and I couldn't even
watch the game and I was signing
autographs and blocking people at night
and it just didn't stop and then I in a
joking way in a sort of Chris Farley way
I just went somebody came up to me about
that's it I'm watching the rest of the
game here we'll talk later and I
remember this kid just kind of turned
and walked like was not happy like oh my
God and I go no no no no no I was just I
was I was kidding and they left and I go
and I still to that day yeah so to this
day feel like I left I let him down well
here's the thing you need to know that
kid tells that story all the time and
he's a dick yeah exactly no I know I
have this inadvertent thing I do when
the only thing you know I'm I'm pretty
good with fans I mean if they come up to
me and you know want you know a photo or
autograph or something yeah exactly but
the only thing it's when somebody goes
data you know and and I'm like
because that isn't actually my name yeah
and um I mean I know what they mean and
I get it and it's just like hey just say
my name but that's a fictional character
and and I am you know a real person yeah
yeah anyway that's understandable my my
son and my wife uh point out to me that
I have this really unfortunate habit
when that happens of rolling my eyes and
going
here we go right and and they say why
can't you be nice why do you have to do
that why can't you just be nice and I
said to my son well why do you think
what happened when I mean like if you
saw Harrison Ford and you went Indy or
you know Han Solo you know don't you
think he'd kind of and he goes I
wouldn't do that
never mind
that's a funny way putting it some
people just don't you know they don't
care I hear it all the time looks yeah
in fact this guy right
um he fixes my house things that go
wrong
um and he always goes you know
um he's hispanic and I you know it's
awesome but in in a fun accent he's
always going Lex you know Lex Luthor
what are we doing to your house today
Rex it's always Lex Luthor Mr Luther
what are we doing I'm like Jesus I don't
say anything I know you know what and he
always asks for things but you know
here's a lunch box here's a here's that
you know I just make people happy but at
some time oh and then it's like you get
my brother and then his son and then you
and it's like all right it's just part
of the course but it's totally
understandable and it is limited of me
not to to react positively to it because
it's a nice it's a good thing it's not a
bad it's better than them going who the
hell are you I don't know yeah it is
though those moments where who do I
think I am really you know yeah I I do I
do that quite often yeah
um quickly on the Stephen Sondheim and
the Brett and Johnny show right I feel
like Jonathan's interviewing me right
now really no no no not at all he's just
oh yeah no no but yeah look if they're
not I know you work with Stephen
Sondheim on Broadway yeah uh yeah son in
the park with children in the park with
George yeah it was fantastic I mean I
mean he's a genius one of the probably
the biggest Legend in Broadway well
certainly the biggest Genius of my
lifetime in the theater oh yeah and the
fact that I got to work with him was
unbelievable
um
I uh I I was so intimidated uh by his
just you know greatness that I I hardly
ever spoke to him and uh I mean he he
gave wonderful notes and and you know
helped a lot with things but what was he
like
um great job Brent that's great that's
great do that no okay no he didn't
really he let the director do that okay
uh but uh but he he did write some
really terrific stuff that I got to sing
and say and uh but uh and he was never
you know unpleasant ever uh he's a
really he was a really really good guy
um but years later
um a friend of mine John Logan really
good friend who who wrote the
screenplay of Sweeney Todd called me and
said
sometimes coming out to LA and we're
gonna have lunch do you want to come yes
so uh I went to lunch
my wife and son came he was very very
small at the time and uh Rick Berman who
produced Star Trek and his family uh
came and it was a big launch well it
wasn't it was his wife there were maybe
six of us all right right and uh
and Saddam and I talked the entire time
we had this great conversation you'd
never really talked not really right and
uh I learned so much about him do you
know that uh do you remember the TV
series topper I vaguely yeah a lot older
than you but uh Leo G Carroll a great
series and uh based on the film stopper
and uh I said is this do you call out to
LA much he said no it's the second time
I've been in years years ago I said what
was the first time he came and he said
well I wrote an episode of topper when I
was 19. and I was like what oh my gosh
to go from that to yeah well he became
yeah but we had a really really uh nice
conversation and he said to John
afterwards uh I can't believe I never
talked to Brent when we were doing the
show we had such a nice Rapport he could
have been best friends with Sondheim I
know but years later I'll do an addendum
if you don't mind years later uh uh
my wife and son and I were in New York
and we went to see uh a friend of ours
Kelsey Grammer in uh because you were on
Frasier I was on Frasier but I knew
Kelsey from the workshop of Sunday in
the park with George and um so we went
to see him in La Casa fall and what
happened to Kelsey in in Sun in the park
was uh I he did he had this moment he
was brilliant in the show really great
uh but he had a moment that he kind of
missed every night and in uh we got
notes after the show in the workshop and
the director
uh who who was a very is a very talented
man James Lapine he uh he didn't have a
vernacular then for talking to actors
really he was new to the game and so he
he he couched it his note in a really
unpleasant way to Kelsey in front of
everyone and Kelsey blew up and said
don't you ever talk to me like that in
front of everyone and it became a really
unfortunate moment so that when we went
to Broadway which was like six months
later Kelsey was not invited to come
because of that moment because of that
moment and um so ironically the week we
started rehearsing Sunday in the park
with George
for Broadway
uh Kelsey got a phone call to go to LA
to audition to play a character called
Frasier on Cheers so if he had been in
the show uh he wouldn't be Frasier right
so when we went to see La Casa fall all
these years later we went afterwards to
a restaurant to eat and sitting behind
us with Sondheim and I said let's go say
hi and he said yeah so we went over and
he was friendly and great as he always
was and he said Kelsey you know you
really owe me a big favor yeah right if
we hadn't fired you you would never have
been Frasier oh my God oh my God did you
I mean did you ever think and were you
sort of well first of all there's this
this could be lore this could be myth
yeah but somewhere I read
that when you were doing your contract
for data for the movies yeah what you
did four movies right
that you put in the contract that I'll
do this but you have to put me in
another movie ever each time is that
true well the first movie uh I I felt I
had some leverage because uh which
actors rarely has yeah so when you
happen particularly actors of my stature
rarely have you know me too you know uh
but uh I I they had a contract they had
it all worked out and I didn't really
want to I knew we had to start shooting
immediately because the script was
already written we finished the series
and two weeks later started the the
movie and so the negotiations got really
intense and really fast yeah and and
basically I said look I'm not doing it
uh unless you know I make x amount of
money and more importantly I get another
role only did that once uh that there
has to be something that's not Star Trek
uh that Paramount Pictures is doing
right now and uh so they they you know
it's a long story but it turned out I I
caught that deal I was the first you
know first maybe an only deal I ever got
that I wanted but
um
but there was a clause in it that if
they didn't find another movie for me to
do uh they had to pay me off you know
some nice figure and as it turned out
they they did not find another movie for
me to do or want to find another movie
for me to do so they just paid me
see I thought the movie was maybe
Independence Day no but in fact before
that all came to a finish I had already
gotten Independence Day so I didn't
really care whether they found me
another movie at that point I thought
well then just pay me and that's fine
was that probably your biggest payday
that first one no and I guess not
because the ones you did sequently those
became paydays right they're gonna give
you a raise on each one yeah exactly wow
yeah that's so cool that you have a
series and you think okay I'm on a TV
series and back then if you were on TV
it didn't you didn't cross over to film
now it's like that you could do whatever
you want you could do you could be a
YouTuber reality star be a movie star
all at the same time right I don't know
if you could be I called a movie star
but whatever yeah but
um
the fact that Star Trek
they wanted the movie version with the
TV cast is probably blew you guys away
well there'd already been a precedent
for it with the original cast oh I guess
that's true that's true so I guess you
always thought that well we thought once
we were quote unquote successful that
maybe there were movies in our future
and and indeed there were I was so upset
when we did Smallville I thought by
season three or four they'd do a movie
of it I was like come on come on it'd be
great everybody would go see it it's the
height and they should have and and
people they would have gone my son by
the way wanted me to tell you how he saw
every episode in love really oh I gotta
give him something just for fun yeah
exactly a small little autographed
lunchbox
um how about your Saturn award we both
have Saturn Awards yes well there was a
segue one yeah that was a good segue
Yeah well yeah I sort of have a Saturn
award why you know I was uh nominated
for a Saturn award back in the day uh
for First Contact the film first Contact
I was up against myself that year for uh
Independence Day right the first
Independence Day for supporting actor in
both cases and um uh you know and there
were there were other people nominated
too but uh but I did win for First
Contact and so I won a Saturday award
but I was in New York at the time doing
a play and uh so my managers
my then managers
um accepted the or took the award and
they kept it in their office and when I
got back from New York they decided to
split uh and go their separate ways so
before they broke the office up I said
uh well can I have my Saturn award and
to the guy I was going with I went with
one rather than the other and he said I
I don't have it oh I'm sure it's still
in the office so I called the other guy
and I said hey uh do you still have you
have my Saturn award he said no I don't
have it and uh what yeah so you don't
have your Saturn award no it's missing
why don't you call it Saturn's Saturn
people well you know what a Saturn
Association
they've asked me to present so give me
an award that I'm doing and I've told
them this story and they uh yeah but
they've never said oh well we'll give me
another one but you know I got a really
weird phone call one day uh it wasn't a
phone call it was an email from someone
a female who was an attorney in Austin
Australia who said I have your Saturn
award do you want it and I said how do
you how do you have my Saturn award and
she said well um
you're somebody my cousin worked for
your managers and uh he you know I wound
up with your Saturn award and I said
well yes I want it and I never heard
from her again
um please if you know any information on
Brent spine or Saturn award please great
P.O box yeah you know uh I have this
thing I want to do uh if I'm ever you
know on stage at the Saturn Awards again
I have this idea that I want to say
listen I tell this story that my Saturn
award disappeared and I'm going to say I
know who took it I know you happen to be
in the audience tonight
no names I'm not that kind of person but
what I'd like right now is for all of us
to go out into the lobby everyone in the
room
10 minutes and when we come back in I
want that siren Warren to be here on on
the days
and then I want to say okay let's go and
see if everybody goes out with me I was
hoping if you presented the or you got
the award and you were there to accept
the award you would have said I want to
thank all the wonderful actors who are
in the category me
um and me but well I've always resented
myself for winning that award by the way
yeah exactly
um
I how difficult was it to say goodbye uh
to data on the first season to pick a
card I mean uh uh at this point no it
wasn't difficult I didn't even think I
was going to do it you know it was just
fun to come back and and have another
shot at it uh it was yeah it was you
nervous how many years had it been
um I don't know 30 years maybe weren't
you a little nervous when I still do
this can I am I or any or you're like I
could just fall back you know I I I
didn't know really if we could still do
it but uh the first day uh I shot was I
shot with Patrick and we were uh on a
stage playing
uh Checkers or chests or something I
haven't seen it but uh uh we looked at
each other we go this is both very
strange and not strange at all all at
the same time yeah it felt very natural
and this third season of Picard of
working with all my friends again people
ask you know was that un weird or
strange or difficult or it wasn't it was
you know it was very easy because we we
know each other really well we're all
friends that's what Jonathan says it was
hard for me to believe that you guys
just all really enjoy each other you
travel together to do cons or you do uh
you know a cruise and you do it but then
we have lunch or we just talk on the
phone or we you know we see each other I
mean you don't get sick of each other no
not at all was there any one person that
you can't mention that was a pain in the
ass that you don't talk to that much
yeah
no no not at all uh to a person we're
all friends and that's kind of great
yeah
I love that do you love being directed
by Jonathan very much uh primarily
because he's a very good director but we
do have a second hand I mean shorthand
sort of thing you know what he wants a
guy got it I got it I know what you want
exactly right and uh that's that's nice
and I'm comfortable with him and he's
comfortable with me and so yeah I love
working with him as director
um is there anything about this the the
uh stunt that you did that you talked
about in some interview or some that
what that was that terrify that's worth
just talking about briefly well I can
tell you yeah John that was Jonathan
directing uh because what was he
directing what was it it was uh it was
uh first Contact first Contact and uh
they needed me to there was a scene
where I was on a we were in a missile
silo Patrick and I were and uh Alfred
Woodard is shooting at us from below and
I say to Patrick I'll take care of this
or I say the Picard or data says to the
card I'll take care of this and I jump
off the platform and go sailing through
the air down to through the floor where
she shoots me in the chest to no avail
right and uh
uh I'm terrified of heights and even
when we were in this missile silo just
standing on the platform I was terrified
uh and Patrick has no fear of heights so
he was bouncing just to you know make me
nervous but anyway
uh the stunt guy did the fall you know
the jump and he jumps through the air
and uh lands on the ground and uh it
looked great and um Jonathan looked at
the dailies and he came to me and he
said uh you gotta do you have to do it
yeah you can tell it's him and I was
like oh God so
what they did was we're in a sound stage
and you know they're very very high and
they rigged me up in a halter and
everything and basically had to take me
up to the top of the Sound Stage and
drop me and uh
so they said we're going to take you up
just a couple of feet so you can feel
what it's like and I said all right so
they took me up a couple feet well I was
ready to throw up at that point that's
you know I don't like I mean for me when
I say I don't like heights I have a
problem with standing uh you know I mean
sitting is semi-comfortable I prefer to
be laying down right but uh so I they
took me down and they said how was that
and I went it was horrible and they said
okay we're gonna take it up a little
further so you can see what it was and I
said no no just let's just do it take me
all the way up because I I'll I'll lose
it if you keep doing it in increments so
they took me all the way up to the top
of the Sound Stage many many feet and
there was a guy on a catwalk because I
was doing this in the wind uh they took
me spinning yeah yeah so they took a
like I had a pole and it straightened me
out yeah so that I would stop spinning
and then they dropped me and uh it you
know the hydraulic kicks in just before
you hit the ground so that he slows down
and um
uh but I got into the right frame of
mind for it I just decided to you know
get into the character just play the
character and and think about my you
know intentions and all that and uh
and I did it and the the crew bursted to
Applause the stunt guys came over and
you know gave me a hat and you know it
was and then Jonathan said I think we
have to do it one more time
but that was oh that was my God and
that's my friend Jonathan that's
Jonathan yeah that's something you hate
he's gonna make you face your maybe he
did it on purpose I'm gonna I'm gonna
help him with his fears but you still
have that fear yup oh totally uh I love
that you you do you're kind of like an
what's the word where you just you're
versatile you do everything it's like
it's almost like you have so many
passions like I mean not only do you do
Broadway TV movies but like you wrote a
book you wrote the Memoir yes and that's
that just came out like two years ago
right a year ago a year ago and where
can people get this uh and on uh Amazon
audible bookstores you sign a lot of
cons I do uh fortunately that means they
bought it yes but uh the audible version
is I think really good if you like
listening to books Patrick Stewart
Jonathan Frank's Michael Dorn LeVar
Burton yourself Marina certis is that
right yeah and Gates McFadden they all
are they do themselves they do they
voice themselves yeah and uh so yeah uh
it was a wonderful experience writing it
and um uh I had the a wonderful person
named Jeannie darst who helped me with
it and uh great writer and then get that
on Amazon or wherever yeah exactly or do
you have a website I don't you don't are
you on Instagram you are uh I am but I
haven't been there in a while I I'm I'm
getting real social media shy
um
can you tell me something that happens
in season three that we won't air until
it happens I play data again what a
reveal you you become data again right
everybody thought it was a goodbye yeah
that was it well I've died twice you
know uh and and very likely will again
at some point not in episode I mean were
you surprised or did you know all along
oh well I knew I I mean the Terry
mattalis who uh wrote
and directed the last two episodes uh
you know we we talked about it before we
started can we do this can I get away
with this how do I do this because data
is different
when you see them again it's a different
data
wow yeah was it cool to play yeah it was
it was it was like really can I pull
this off because he is different he's uh
he's not
he's he's you know there was a thing
Roddenberry I'll say this really briefly
but from the very beginning Rod Mary
said uh here's what I want from data I
want him to get as The Show Goes On get
closer and closer and closer to being
human and by the end still not and that
continues along this thing because he's
much much closer to human but still not
wow
that's awesome yeah tell me about the
Brent and Johnny show yes it's yeah the
Brent Johnny show it is in the works
we're we're kind of formulating it right
now but uh we're going to do it uh and
it's basically a reality show uh it's
it's kind of a cross between uh oh I
don't remember Jonathan has a whole list
of shows that like Pickers and things
like that that it's similar to because
we're basically on the road uh but it is
uh you know you know what Cameo is right
yes yeah well it's kind of the ultimate
Cameo uh in that you know people write
in Cameo and they want a video a little
short video greeting or birthday
something or birthday anniversary yeah
pep talk yes that sort of thing uh and
this is sort of the ultimate Cameo
because uh we we don't just send you a
little video we come to your house and
uh and it's kind of make a wish only and
crossed with Pickers and uh you know and
we help you would do things that you
want us to do dirty jobs uh what you
know whatever you need us to do we'll do
it will come we'll be there with you
we'll you know we'll do whatever you
want and yeah if if this goes and it's a
big success yeah if you do season two do
a celebrity version and I'll and I'll
call you to have somebody well you know
what in fact uh our idea at the moment I
don't know how this is going to work out
but uh the idea is obviously we're going
to do the wraparounds for the whole
thing and host it and do most of the
episodes but we we also are going to ask
other people to go in our stead you know
if somebody wants somebody else like
Michael Rosenberg
people do that though blue uh Berg and
I'm like I'm not your Rabbi you know
what I said this last night to my son
and he said it's Rosenbaum you know yeah
but everybody messes it up so what if I
called you Brett Spiner uh they do they
do or how about Brett spainer spinner
we may be calling you and saying hey
Michael do you want to do one of these
with us yeah great and so that's it and
and that's what we're coming to your
house and uh there is a a uh a website I
mean an email Brent and Johnny show
that's j-o-n-n-y Brent and Johnny show
one word gmail.com and uh send us your
requests and if you need us to come for
what reason and you know you're gonna
get it and then you're gonna get a lot
of responses yeah and then we get to
pick the ones we want to do right yeah I
love it yeah all right this is rapid
fire you're answering like quick
question then we're done ready yeah this
is uh my patrons it's [__] talking with
Brett Steiner
um uh my patrons patreon.com talkville
if you want to support the podcast and
help us out we love you uh Rousey when
you first read the script for your
character on Night Court what did you
think a piece of cake I've been doing
that character in Houston Texas all my
life and so I thought can I do this and
they hired me Leanne what has been your
favorite and least thing about playing
data what makes them so likable uh my
favorite thing about playing data uh it
was uh you know he's he's who wouldn't
want to play data I got to be this
wonderful accessible character and all
kinds of other characters that data
played it being uh so it was a it was a
limitless character Nico P what was it
like joining Will Wheaton on The Big
Bang Theory uh where each you each got
to play yourselves as characters great
the easiest job of my life it took me
longer to get there than it did to
actually do the part little Lisa do you
have any fun stories you could share
when you were filming Independence Day
or just a brief one quickly uh yeah uh
uh well again I I worked with my friend
Randy Quaid uh who I I'd known since we
were in high school together and uh
there came a moment where he was on
camera and I was off camera doing
something that the director told me to
do and he stopped and went God stop
you've been doing this since high school
that's amazing uh Maddie s can you share
any crazy memories from the Star Trek
fan cruises any one memory particular
that comes out you know what there's
nothing crazy they're they're actually
very nice the fans are very lovely and
and respectful and we get to hang out
with tons of our friends who are on the
cruise and we have a really great time
oh man I mean how's your life now how do
you feel when you can look back are you
able to kind of every once in a while
just go look at look at this you yeah
look this kid from Houston yeah I mean
sometimes I feel like that I mean you
know it's it's all kind of it's a
double-edged sword with one side being
incredibly great and the other side
being a little and that's just that you
know being known for a character in
particular uh is nothing I ever dreamed
about you know my idea of what I wanted
to do was as many things as possible and
I've done a lot of things and that's the
good side uh it's just that the
association with one character by so
many people uh it's a little you know
sure and you have to think though it's
so rare for someone to embrace a
character
universally right that you think how is
that gonna happen all there's three
different roles and they'll like it and
I'll be able to but it's like this boom
yeah everybody knows you you are that
you are awesome we love you and it's
great and it's awesome awesome but it's
like you're uh you're a thespian you've
always done theater you've always wanted
to do theater you've always wanted to
explore and do all these things so I get
that yeah I mean and and I think
sometimes like uh in terms of doing
other films or TV things I haven't been
cast in that you know it's either
because they say no that's data
everybody else that's data well that's
that's actually the upside the downside
is it's just no you're lousy that's why
we didn't cast you uh listen you
promised you you come back indeed I love
this you're so easy to talk to you know
there's so much to else to explore
um can I throw one more question in
because you gotta hurry well because my
friend Rudy I told him you were coming
and he freaked ice any thousand
questions
I'll just pick one uh what's the most
valuable lesson about Humanity you learn
from playing a non-human trying to be
human but I I gosh that's deep ready
that's a little bit too deep no I was
just trying to learn my life yeah
so I can go to sleep all right what's
your favorite data heavy episode then uh
um name some
he says his is the one where there's a
trial about uh whether data qualifies
about being a living being right that
was called Measure of a Man and that was
that was a really excellent episode
written by Melinda Snodgrass my maybe my
favorite is The Offspring because
Jonathan it was the first thing he ever
directed and actually my book fan
fiction is uh kind of Set uh The
Offspring Centric you'll you'll see what
I mean if you read it fan fiction
yes I mean you get the audible and
listen to all these amazing people yeah
you'll enjoy it I I know you I'm gonna
do it yeah I'm gonna do it in my car all
right that didn't sound right yeah this
has been an absolute Joy I already love
you I'm gonna message you to see how
you're doing and this will uh this will
Air I'll let you know you'll let me know
yeah we'll be in touch okay thanks for
doing this uh my pleasure uh you're easy
to talk to too thank you and uh all you
want to talk about is me who doesn't
want to do that I know well I I like it
I like I liked it next time let's talk
about other people yeah you know then
we're really like the Hollywood scene
exactly do we talk about others exactly
all right thank you thanks Michael
pretty cool yeah pretty cool such a a a
good dude and I love that story about
like his kids are like Dad when the
guy's like
calling him out or whatever that's what
I was thinking I actually have a name
um you know it's true it's like you know
hey it's like but it's just I I I've
heard it all the time so people just
deal with it differently and some people
get into it I remember there was a time
when I was I got annoying people go it
looks you know it's just you know it's
par for the course but you know I mean
you like it because 99 of the fans don't
they're cool Michael hey yeah you know
it's it's you know I've learned to just
take everything in stride and I think he
has too at this point he's got a big way
bigger following than I do
um but I really appreciated that
conversation it was fun wasn't it it was
really good yeah it was very kind of
advanced for all the questions there was
a lot of uh yeah Star Trek questions and
yeah and he didn't have any problems he
just uh I think he really enjoyed it so
um thank you Brent Spiner
and please subscribe if you dug it
that's all I'm going to ask and write a
review and all that stuff and patreon
join patreon today patreon.com
insideview join the other patrons who
are supporting the podcast and keeping
it afloat if you're if you really dig it
you want it to stick around hey
I got you and now without further Ado
you know we should do you know what we
should do right now what should we do we
should read the top tier patrons okay do
you think that's important I think so I
mean that's part of the perks
it's part of it if here it listen if
you're a patron you're gonna get your
name if you're a top tier Patron you're
gonna get your name read off
as well you should
and maybe we should keep that accent
through the entire
really or it's gonna get kind of boring
let's see how it goes
Nancy D Leah ass little Lisa okay
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason w
Sophie M Rossi Joshua D now you can get
a little bit Jennifer and Stacy Hill
Gmail F Janelle B
Santiago M Chad w e n p Janine R Maya P
Maddie s Belinda and Dave a Sheila G uh
Bradley Ray H Tabitha T Tom and Liliana
a Italian bit CD Chad Al Dan in
alert message Angel and ran and see Cory
K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy
D Camellias Joey M Eugene and Leah Corey
Heather L Jake B Megan T Angela F Mel s
Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Eric H Shane
R and Emma R Andrew r m is that oichi
oh 77. Andreas I don't know I don't know
and Oracle Karina and Amanda R gen B
Kevin e Stephanie cage or lgm and J Lee
NJ Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone H Miss s
Brian L Katie B Aaron R Kendall L House
of Joel Meredith I Prof doctor scoots
Charlene C Cara C Mary R Kyle F and
Marisol p
those are the top tier pod uh patrons
thank you for the support and love I
will do a top tier uh Zoom sometime in
the near future also a a YouTube for the
patrons is going to come up
and do a YouTube live I like to play
songs and they tell me what to play and
we ask questions and it's kind of a fun
thing maybe you should join me on one of
those I would love to ask Ryan anything
I accidentally walk in on some of your
sessions yeah you do and I joined it for
about five minutes
five minutes and they love it they love
it there for about five minutes thank
you for listening to the podcast we love
you and uh I can do it without you so
from the Hollywood Hills in Hollywood
California I'm Michael Rosenbaum I'm a
ladies and gentlemen
Lounge stuff here we got a great show
and uh thank you thank you for kindly
listening to the show and um
be good to yourselves
good night
was that a decent Johnny Carson
yeah because I mean to me the the Johnny
Carson I hear is the Dana Carvey
impression so I think that's pretty
close yeah it was so cold last night how
cold was it so cold I saw a robin
putting his worm in the microwave
weird wild stuff
see you guys
[Music]